Hi Leute!
Na, wo geht ihr am liebsten draußen essen?
Ist vielleicht Subway einer der Kandidaten, wo ihr gerne mal einen Sub verspeist?
Ich mag's ganz gerne, also zwischendurch gehen Hamza und ich gerne mal nach Subway.
Und was wir dann immer, wirklich immer kaufen ist ein Cookie!
(H: Nein, nein, nein, das ist nicht so! Es ist einfach so: Ich kauf einen Cookie und du isst den von mir weg!)
Ja Hamza kauft und ich sag dann erstmal: "Ja neeeein, ich will nicht!"
(H: Und ich frag noch extra!)
Und dann...
Gönn ich!
(H: Kiki, willst du auch einen eigenen? "Nein, ich möchte nicht!")
Naja, so sind wir halt! Aber ist ja nicht schlimm!
Jetzt wo ich weiß, dass ich die auch zuhause ganz einfach nachmachen kann...
muss ich garnicht mehr...
(H: Isst du sie mir auch...du isst sie mir auch hier weg!)
Ja, natürlich! Aber man kann halt auch mal..man muss nicht das Haus verlassen, um Subway Geschmack
zuhause zu haben.
Ich weiß, dass Cookies backen überhaupt keine Kunst ist, also Cookies sind total einfach zu machen.
Aber ich habe die perfekten Mengenangaben gefunden, die perfekte Konsistenz,
die Art und Weise, wie ihr eben dieses "klitschige" herbekommt, dieses "chewy"...einfach richtig lecker!
Ich will euch jetzt gar nicht auf die Folter spannen, ich zeige euch jetzt hier mal die Zutaten, die wir benötigen.
Die habt ihr auch sicher fast alle zuhause!
Also wir benötigen zimmerwarme Butter, außerdem Mehl und Backpulver.
Hier hab ich ein Ei, braunen Zucker oder auch Rohrzucker,
dann hab ich hier Macadamianüsse. Eventuell eine Prise Salz, White Chocolate Chunks und Vanilleextrakt.
Und ich lüge nicht wenn im Titel steht "5 Minuten Subway Cookies", weil ich-
(H: *lacht* Du hast gesagt fast!)
Ich bin stolz weil es sind wirklich nur 5min Zubereitungszeit und den Rest macht der Backofen,
also das ist ja nicht dann eure Arbeit, versteht ihr?
(H: Also ihr merkt, ihr merkt heute sind wir crazy drauf!)
Wir sind crazy drauf! Wir geben jetzt die zimmerwarme Butter in unsere Rührschüssel,
zusammen mit dem braunen Zucker und dann wird das ganze 2min lang gemixt.
Nach den 2-3min gebt ihr das Ei hinzu und rührt das gerade so unter, bis es sich vermengt hat mit der Masse.
Das dauert wirklich nur 10sek und mehr nicht!
Jetzt nehmen wir uns das Mehl und das Backpulver und sieben das in die Masse hinein.
Und auch das wieder nur so lange verrühren, bis es sich gerade so verbunden hat.
Jetzt hab ich das Vanilleextrakt auch dazugegeben und wir haben einen recht festen Teig,
das ist genau richtig so.
Und da geben wir jetzt die Macadamianüsse rein und aus meinem Shop die weißen Chocolate Chunks.
Und falls ihr die Macadamianüsse schon geröstet und gesalzen bekommt, dann nehmt die gerne.
Denn ihr wisst ja in süßen Sachen hebt Salz immer so ein bisschen den Geschmack.
Und falls ihr das eben nicht gesalzen herbekommt, dann einfach eine Prise Salz mit hinzugeben.
Aber ich hab die gesalzenen, daher brauch ich das in dem Fall nicht.
So ihr Süßen, jetzt schnappt ihr euch euer Backblech, gebt da ein Backpapier oben drüber
und jetzt kommen die Cookies auch schon drauf.
Tut mir nur einen Gefallen: Nehmt immer 6 Cookies für ein Backblech,
weil die werden ja noch ein bisschen in die Breite gehen im Ofen.
Und daher wollen wir ja nicht, dass wir am Ende so einen Riesencookie auf dem Backblech haben
und die alle zusammenkleben!
(H: Wäre auch nicht schlecht, ein Riesencookie!)
Obwohl genau, das wär eigentlich auch nicht schlecht!
Jetzt nehm ich mir noch die angefeuchteten Hände und drück die noch so ganz leicht flach
und den Rest erledigt ja wirklich der Ofen, den hab ich auch schon vorgeheizt auf 180 Grad
Ober-  und Unterhitze.
Und jetzt aufgepasst: Jeder Backofen ist anders, jeder Backofen ist individuell,
daher achtet drauf, schaut nach 10min, nach 11 und nach 12.
Ganz wichtig: sie müssen noch richtig hell sein, der Rand darf nur minimal goldbraun sein.
Denn alles andere ist dann schon zu trocken, denn wir wollen ja, dass sie chewy bleiben
und ich zeig euch gleich das Endergebnis!
Und fertig sind die White Choc Macadamia Nut Cookies wie von Subway!
Und ihr dürft mir gerne in die Kommentare schreiben welches Rezept ich als nächstes nachmachen soll.
Gerne auch was herzhaftes, man kann ja auch mal die Subway Subs nachmachen!
Weil das geht auch super easy!
(H: Ohaaaa!)
Oder? Gute Idee, ne?
Also es gibt natürlich 1000 Varianten aber
(H: Daran hab ich gar nicht gedacht!)
Meine Lieblingsvariante ist mit Thunfisch, zum Beispiel...
ja welches Brot essen wir nochmal?
(H: Das ist doch eigentlich recht einfach!)
Ja, sag ich ja! Das ist total easy!
(H: Ja, lass machen!)
Ihr backt das Brot und dann könnt ihr das beliebig belegen.
(H: Schreibt in die Kommentare, dass wir's machen sollen!)
Genau, schreibt ihr. Wir brachen nochmal so eine Bestätigung von euch
und dann machen wir das Ganze!
Und euch jetzt ganz viel Freude beim Nachbacken!
Schaut in die Videobeschreibung, da stehen alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben.
Und dann schickt ihr mir bitte eure Fotos oder postet sie, das ist noch besser
mit dem Hashtag #kikiskitchen auf Instagram. Ja Hamza was ist?
(H: Nichts, das wollte ich eigentlich sagen:( Aber egal!)
Achso ja ok, alles klar!
Ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel Freude beim Nachbacken!
Bis dann, tschüss!
(H: Heute waren wir ganz schön crazy, oder?)
Heute waren wir echt crazy!